I mean look at Guardians I mean Zoe was
somewhat of an established name when we
started out but she you know she was the
biggest star we had Chris wasn't and he
was the Chris wasn't a star exactly he
was not a star you know and and Dave
Batista was not even known that's why it
kind of worked that's why it worked I
don't think it's because of that that it
worked I think that if we had a big star
who came in and killed a Star-Lord it
would have done well but I think that
it's about the performances first and
foremost and that when you have you know
characters like uh you know and those
were unknown characters by the way the
characters were not celebrities nobody I
mean a couple hundred thousand people
read Guardians Comics before the movie
came out yeah and they also changed a
lot over the years so there was no real
fan base just you know I didn't know
what the hell it was yeah I didn't know
what Guardians of the Galaxy was I
hadn't read the comics I wasn't I was a
horror movie fangori I know you read
fangoria so I wasn't so it was like it
was all it was definitely a like a it
was a risk yeah it was a risk because
people it wasn't something I mean like
Superman that they know okay we know
this we're it's you know Chris Pratt
gave a speech at the end of you know as
we were wrapping up um the third movie
and he gave us beautiful speech and he
was crying I didn't cry at all he was
crying profusely this is what he does
with Pratt this is their joke so he was
very much crying like a baby and it was
it was a little embarrassing and how
much went on and cried like I gotta say
understand that this is not what the
story is about but it was sort of
embarrassing how much yeah he was a big
baby big baby and people yeah a lot of
people were snickering I wasn't you know
a lot of people were laughing his wife
was embarrassed is well if we ever show
the tape like in the behind the scenes
she's gonna yeah it's cringy
um no no he gave this beautiful speech
and in the speech what he get he was
reading off he went back and he looked
up all of the the articles that were
written about the Guardians before the
movie came out and he's quoting you know
this is going to be Marvel's first bomb
this is and it was just all this stuff
about nobody caring about these
characters you know wow and it was you
cried what you cried I I cried I got I
got I got I got teary I got teary I got
a male very masculine tier sure but I
will admit I tried a lot it's Zoe's
speech it was really yeah okay I think
yeah I don't know if you're [__] with
Pratt again on that I'm not I think he
probably gets jealous when I say that
but it's true I cried I cried a lot in
Her speech I wish people knew about they
were there on your wedding day when
Pratt read the um so James wrote
something for Pratt to read
and I'm not kidding I could not stop
laughing
everyone was just and it was like I have
everything I am to James Gunn without me
I'd still be the heavy set it was it
just went and it was like his wife's
much prettier than my wife I and it was
just and it went on yeah I wrote a
speech for Chris and he's he's read it
at the wedding and I've never shared
this but it's like I read this beat yeah
and he wrote this and he comes up and
goes
um you know my name is Chris Pratt and
uh and then he goes on bio everything
yeah yeah he talks about how foxy my
wife is and how of course he's reading
with James Rose he's like can I marry
Catherine she's pretty good you know I
mean he he would break and he's like I'm
sorry Catherine I didn't uh you know and
uh and he he goes on and he talked about
how much better the Guardians movies are
than the Jurassic Park movie or the
Jurassic World movies yes
he was so funny he was so funny oh the
way he delivered it and uh and people
afterwards were like you know because
his acting was so good people were like
did you really not read that till you
went up there well pasta people were
like Chris did you really right I saw
that at first I was like yeah you
actually write this and it's like no no
I wrote it but he and then the other
half were like did you really not read
it before you went up there and because
he goes uh because he acted like he
hadn't read the speech before he started